y sabíamos que lo era porque estábamos trabajando con él.
Pero supe qué quiso decir,
porque sería posible tomar un montón de fotos
de flores en el jardín y entonces, básicamente, ordenarlas
en un sistema informático tal que pareciera
que había un robot real cuando no lo había.
Y cuanto más pensaba en esto no se me ocurría
en una buena respuesta para que él pudiese distinguir la diferencia.
Fue justo cuando me ofrecieron una posición
aquí en Berkeley;
cuando llegué, busqué a Hubert Dreyfus,
profesor de filosofía de renombre mundial,
y hablé con él de esto, y me dijo:
"Este es uno de los problemas más antiguos y más fundamentales
de la filosofía. Nos remonta a los escépticos,
y de ahí a Descartes.
Es un problema epistemológico,
el estudio de como sabemos cuando algo es verdad.
Así, comenzamos a trabajar juntos
y acuñamos un nuevo término: 'telepistemología',
el estudio del conocimiento a la distancia.
Invitamos a artistas, ingenieros
y filósofos destacados para escribir ensayos sobre esto
y los resultados, los resultados están compilados en este libro
de la MIT Press.
Entonces, gracias a este estudiante que cuestionó
aquello que los demás supusieron que era verdad,
este proyecto me enseñó una lección importante sobre la vida,
y es que siempre hay que cuestionar las suposiciones.
Ahora, les contaré del segundo proyecto
surgido del Tele-jardín.
Conforme operaba, con mis alumnos estuvimos muy interesados
en la interacción de la gente entre sí
y en lo que estaban haciendo con el jardín.
Así comenzamos a pensar: ¿Y si el robot pudiera dejar
el jardín e ir a algún otro
ambiente interesante?
Como, por ejemplo, ¿Y si pudiera ir a una cena
a la Casa Blanca? (Risas)
Por esta razón nos estábamos interesando más en el diseño de sistemas
y en la interfaz del usuario que en el hardware,
decidimos en vez de tener
un robot para remplazar al humano para ir a la cena,
tendríamos un humano para remplazar al robot.
Lo llamamos el Tele-actor.
Conseguimos un humano,
alguien que fuera muy cordial y sociable,
equipada con un casco
con varios equipos, cámaras y micrófonos,
y luego una mochila con una conexión a Internet inalámbrica,
y la idea fue que ella podía ir a un ambiente remoto
interesante y entonces, a través de la Internet,
la gente podía vivir lo experimentado por ella
y ver lo visto por ella,
pero entonces, incluso más importante, podían participar,
interactuando el uno con el otro;
llegando a ideas sobre lo siguiente que ella debía hacer;
a dónde debería ir;
y transmitírselo al Tele-actor.
Tuvimos la oportunidad de llevar el Tele-actor
a la premiación de los "Webby Awards" en San Francisco.
Ese año el anfitrión fue Sam Donaldson.
Justamente antes de levantarse la cortina, tuve alrededor de 30 segundos
para explicarle al Sr. Donaldson qué haríamos.
Le dije: "El Tele-actor
lo va a acompañar a Ud. en el escenario;
esto es un nuevo proyecto experimental;
la gente en sus pantallas la estará observando;
ella está equipada con cámaras,
micrófonos y un audífono en su oído;
y la gente desde la red le da recomendaciones
sobre lo siguiente a hacer".
Y él dijo: "Espera un segundo,
eso es lo que yo hago". (Risas)
Por tanto, le encantó el concepto.
Cuando el Tele-actor entró al escenario,
ella caminó directo a él y le dio un gran beso
justo en los labios. (Risas)
Estábamos totalmente sorprendidos.
No teníamos idea de lo que sucedería.
Él estuvo genial. Sólo le dio a ella un gran abrazo en retorno
y funcionó muy bien.
Pero esa noche, mientras empacábamos,
pregunté a la tele-actriz cómo decidieron los Tele-directores
que le diera un beso a Sam Donaldson.
Ella dijo: no lo decidieron.
Ella cuenta que cuando caminaba sobre el escenario,
los Tele-directores estaban aún tratando de llegar a un acuerdo sobre qué hacer,
entonces ella sólo se dirigió al escenario e hizo
lo que sintió más natural. (Risas)
Así, el éxito del Tele-actor aquella noche
fue debido al hecho que ella fue una maravillosa actriz
Ella supo cuando confiar en sus instintos,
y por tanto el proyecto me enseñó otra lección sobre la vida,
que es, ante la duda, improvisa. (Risas)
Bueno, el tercer proyecto surgió
de mi experiencia cuando mi padre estuvo en el hospital,
sometiéndose a un tratamiento
de quimioterapia, relacionado con otro tratamiento
llamado braquiterapia, en el que se colocan "semillas" pequeñas, radioactivas
en el cuerpo para tratar tumores cancerosos.
Y la forma de hacerlo, como pueden ver aquí...
los cirujanos insertan agujas en el cuerpo
para liberar las semillas,
todas estas semillas en paralelo,
así es muy común penetrar órganos
sensibles a las agujas y, como resultado,
las agujas causan daño a estos órganos, y este daño
produce traumas y efectos secundarios.
Así mis estudiantes y yo nos preguntamos, ¿qué tal si pudiéramos
modificar el sistema
para que las agujas pudieran llegar en diferentes ángulos?
Simulamos esto y desarrollamos algunos
algoritmos de optimización; lo simulamos
y pudimos demostrar que seríamos capaces de evitar
los órganos delicados y aún así lograr la cobertura
de los tumores con radiación.
Y ahora, estamos trabajando con médicos de la Universidad de California en San Francisco
e ingenieros de John Hopkins
y construimos un robot que tiene un número de,
es un diseño especializado con diferentes articulaciones que permiten
que las agujas se acerquen en una variedad infinita de ángulos
y, como pueden ver aquí, pueden evitar órganos delicados
y aún así alcanzar los objetivos pretendidos por ellas.
Entonces, al cuestionar la suposición de que todas las agujas
tienen que ser paralelas, este proyecto me enseñó
una lección importante:
Cuando tu camino está bloqueado, pivota.
Y el último proyecto tiene relación con la cirugía robótica.
Y esto es algo que nació a partir del sistema llamado
robot quirúrgico Da Vinci;
es un dispositivo que está disponible comercialmente.
Lo usan unos 2000 hospitales en el mundo,
y la idea es permitirle a los cirujanos
operar cómodamente en su propio marco de coordenadas
y muchas de las tareas menores en cirugía
son muy rutinarias y tediosas, como suturar,
y actualmente, todas éstas son realizadas
bajo el específico e inmediato control del cirujano,
causando fatiga al cirujano con el tiempo.
Y nos habíamos preguntado:
¿Y si pudiéramos programar al robot
para realizar algunas de estas tareas menores,
y de este modo liberar a los cirujanos para que se concentren
en las partes más complicadas de la cirugía
y también reducir el tiempo que lleva la cirugía?
¿Y si pudiéramos conseguir que el robot las haga un poco más rápido?
Bueno, es difícil programar un robot para hacer actividades delicadas
como ésta, pero resulta que mi colega, Pieter Abbeel,
que ha desarrollado aquí en Berkeley
unas nuevas técnicas para enseñar a los robots con ejemplos.
De esta forma, ha conseguido robots que vuelan helicópteros,
que hacen acrobacias increíbles, interesantes y bellas
con sólo observar cómo pilotean expertos humanos.
Así, conseguimos uno de esos robots.
Comenzamos a trabajar con Pieter y sus estudiantes
y le pedimos a un cirujano que realice
una tarea, y al robot
le pedimos al robot...
el cirujano realiza la tarea,
y nosotros registramos los movimientos del robot.
Aquí tenemos un ejemplo. Usaré un ocho como figura,
rastrearemos la figura de ocho como ejemplo.
Aquí está cómo se ve cuando el robot...
así se ven las trayectorias del robot,
esos tres ejemplos.
Bueno, son mucho mejores que los que un novato
como yo podría hacer pero aún son erráticos e imprecisos.
Así registramos todos estos ejemplos, los datos,
y luego seguimos una secuencia de pasos.
Primero, usamos un técnica llamada deformación temporal dinámica
del reconocimiento de voz y esto nos permitió
alinear temporalmente todos los ejemplos,
y entonces aplicamos un filtro de Kalman,
una técnica de teoría de control, que nos permite
analizar estadísticamente todos los ruidos
y extraer la trayectoria deseada subyacente.
Lo que hicimos fue tomar estos
ejemplos humanos, ruidosas e imperfectas;
de ellas extrajimos una trayectoria inferida de la tarea;
y la secuencia de control para el robot.
Luego ejecutamos esto en el robot,
observamos qué ocurre,
ajustamos los controles usando una secuencia de técnicas
llamada aprendizaje iterativo.
Incrementamos la velocidad un poco.
Observamos los resultados, ajustamos los controles de nuevo,
y observamos lo ocurrido.
Y hacemos esto en varias rondas.
Y este es el resultado.
Esta es la trayectoria inferida de la tarea,
y aquí tenemos al robot moviéndose a la velocidad del humano.
Aquí es cuatro veces la velocidad del humano.
Aquí es siete veces.
Y aquí está el robot operando a 10 veces
la velocidad del humano.
Así, pudimos lograr que un robot realice tareas delicadas,
como un tarea quirúrgica menor,
a 10 veces la velocidad de un humano.
Así este proyecto también, gracias a la práctica y el aprendizaje
que conllevó, hacer algo una y otra vez,
este proyecto también deja una lección y es que
si quieren hacer algo bien,
no hay sustituto a la práctica, práctica, práctica.
Estas son las cuatro lecciones que he aprendido
de los robots a través de los años,
y la robótica, el campo de la robótica ha mejorado mucho
con el tiempo.
Hoy en día, los alumnos de secundaria pueden construir robots
como el robot industrial que mi papá y yo tratamos de construir.
Y ahora, tengo una hija,
llamada Odessa.
Tiene ocho años de edad.
y también le gustan los robots.
Quizá lo llevamos en la sangre. (Risas)
¡Cómo deseo que hubiese podido conocer a papá!
Y ahora yo debo enseñarle cómo funcionan las cosas.
Construimos proyectos juntos, y me pregunto:
¿qué clase de lecciones aprenderá de ellos?
Los robots son las más humanas
de nuestras máquinas.
Ellos no pueden resolver todos los problemas del mundo,
pero pienso que tienen algo importante para enseñarnos.
Los invito a pensar en las innovaciones
que les interesen,
en las máquinas que desean,
y piensen en qué podrían decirles,
porque tengo la corazonada
de que muchas de nuestras innovaciones tecnológicas,
los instrumentos soñados por nosotros,
pueden inspirarnos a ser mejores humanos.
Gracias. (Aplausos)